this is a stressful day because it puts
a lot of pressure on a relationship
I'm still not sure I want to be in I'm
very impressed with myself that I got
reservations you cannot afford this but
I'm gonna make this year very special if
I can slack off in the future
realizing you will never understand how
much money I actually spent to get ready
too many Oh this menu is a lot more
expensive than I expected and it doesn't
include life there's a $40 song writing
straight up my [ __ ] transferring
money from my savings to my checking
just in case you want some wine [ __ ]
about my perfect calming my nerves cuz
I'm gonna tell you that I love you for
the first time tonight just to make this
a little more special hi guys I will be
making eye contact with both of you as I
go over our very very expensive prefix
menu which only contains two options the
reason we do that is we need to flip as
many tables as possible we need to make
the most money we can tonight I hate
your love and I hate this holiday
thanks so much oh I'm needing a picture
for social media to make all my friends
jealous you wanna tell the world I
laughs this is good everyone here's
having sex my boomy Kelsey I oh my god
it tell me I'm ready validation I was
gonna say that
are you trying not to play into every
attribute of my stereotypical general
but these guys are making me feel so
[ __ ] feminine how I feel so upstage
time you know come see maybe this is a
good time right I love you I love you
I'm cheating on you I want to say it
first